let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads
explode let me be clear before this
podcast begins
we are loud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not
liberty you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah
the smell of freedom of speech this is
the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
well good wednesday afternoon everybody
thanks for joining me here on let's talk
the
tony michaels podcast episode
number 19 19
weeks we've been doing this [ __ ] you
guys
keep watching more and more of you
so thank you for that we have some
subjects to talk about today
these republicans always give me [ __ ] to
talk about
every [ __ ] week something happens on
a goddamn wednesday
i did not plan that originally
it was not planned that way but if you
go back and you watch a lot of the
episodes
for some reason the universe really
aligns for
wednesdays for me to talk into a
microphone
and for you you folks to listen
our very first episode the very first
one
was they voted to impeach donald trump
the second time and then
and then we had an episode on wednesday
january 20th which was the inauguration
you know the day that donald trump was
supposed to take over the world and joe
biden was supposed to step aside
and here we are here we are
months later and today
mitch mcconnell kevin mccarthy and these
[ __ ]
stupid manga trump humping [ __ ] in
congress hand me up more [ __ ] to talk
about
they're not going to do a january 6
commission by god they don't want to
look into themselves
that ain't what they want to do they
don't want to incriminate themselves are
you kidding me
so we're going to talk about that today
obviously the other thing i want to
touch on today
is the trump organization
and this is what i i thought today was
going to be about
last night it was announced that the
new york attorney general was joining
the manhattan district attorney
in a criminal investigation into the
trump organization
now trump an organization that's kind of
an oxymoron
but that's what the [ __ ] those idiots
called it
so the trump org
the investigation into donald trump
and his family and their business is now
a criminal matter
as far as the state of new york is
concerned so they're going to be joining
the manhattan d.a in their investigation
and if you remember a while back
the supreme court decided that they
would allow the manhattan d.a to present
donald trump's tax returns to a grand
jury
now rather that is the the the thing
that has triggered
the new york attorney general to to take
their case from a civil case to criminal
case i guess we'll find out in the near
future
but there's a lot of stuff swarming
around these maga trump humpers and
these
criminal types these two and on
criminal types that's really
you know it seems like it's all tied
together and the dots all lead back
to donald j trump their orange deity
so we'll break that down a little bit
today too
but the first thing i want to talk about
is what happened yesterday and
it kind of got lost in the mix but it is
a very important subject here in this
country right now
of why we are letting these [ __ ] get
away with this
and why we continue to pretend that this
problem is something that it's not
and that is yesterday uh the north
carolina d.a
district attorney in north carolina came
out and announced that he will not be
pressing charges on the officers
who murdered andrew brown and he he
played the the tape of the body cam over
and over and over and over again
and he thought well that'll settle it
the media will see that
i'll tell them [ __ ] them and by god they
won't question me a bit
and it'll be over well that was not what
happened
when the media seen the tape right there
in real contemporary time
they're like what the [ __ ]
he didn't try to run over with the car
the officer tried to step in front of
the car
a bit when he pulled away but he didn't
try to kill him with the car
he wasn't using the car as a weapon and
when he did pull away
they turned it into swiss cheese as it
was driving away
and we pretend we pretend like this
[ __ ] white gun culture isn't existing
inside law enforcement like it's
existing inside the rest of the country
you know what i'm talking about if
you're afraid of something kill it
and the best way to kill something is
with a gun
especially especially if you're a white
person and
the threat that you have to eliminate
those were hers
his words not mine the threat that you
have to eliminate
is a black man
so i did a video about that of course
a tick tock
you guys always like the tiki talks that
i do
so let's i'm gonna play that tick tock
on this subject of andrew brown
and then we'll talk about this on the
other side i don't have a lot of
material
uh queued up for this and the reason why
is because
we haven't seen the rest of the goddamn
body cam tapes
we haven't seen the rest of the evidence
the public hasn't been reassured
that an actual investigation took place
which from the camera footage that they
did provide
from from the way that they decided not
to press charges it doesn't seem like
there was
much of investigation at all if any
especially when the press started to to
question him on why he made the
decisions he made based on
that exact tape that body cam footage
so let's watch that video here real
quick extinguish a threat
let's talk so today a district attorney
in north carolina decides that the
police murdering of andrew brown
was justified of course they think that
the police killing of a black man is
justified
jesus [ __ ] cry any more [ __ ] times
we're gonna have to do this before we
admit as a country what the [ __ ] is
actually going on here riding is all
over the wall
or the white culture gun safe as it were
and you know what i'm talking about when
you're completely terrified of something
the best thing to do is kill it best way
to kill it is kill it with a gun
the best weapon to extinguish a threat
with is a highly efficient
semi-automatic killing machine
obviously in this great country when the
threat to extinguish is a black man
pew pew pew pew stop bullshitting
ourselves america just because the
highly effective killing machine
sometimes isn't a semi-automatic weapon
and it's a chokehold
or kneeling on someone in the prom
position it's still part of the [ __ ]
culture
[ __ ] them
well there you go it's the white gun
culture i've talked about it on here
before
it continues and continues and continues
and it doesn't have to be
killing black people or people of color
with a gun
it's still a culture the culture is
if something is deemed a threat to our
way of life our whiteness
and by god if it moves or if it doesn't
do what it's told or it doesn't comply
the death penalty is what we will apply
to it
and the easiest way for a for a police
officer to eliminate a threat
is with a gun and it's really easy when
the culture
is the easiest most efficient way to
eliminate a threat
people of color in particular black men
a gun is the most efficient way to do it
that's the culture that's what we've
created
we continue to perpetuate this nonsense
by not passing police reform by not
making sure
that knuckleheads don't have guns i
don't care if you're just an
ordinary citizen or a [ __ ] cop
if you watch the footage they were in
the back of the truck they were armed to
the tooth
and they were ready to [ __ ] shoot
something they were
[ __ ] ready and i would bet i would
bet a lot of money
a lot of [ __ ] money that the reason
why they don't release that the rest of
the [ __ ] body cam footage
because we can only [ __ ] imagine the
conversations
that those officers who were holding
those semi-automatic rifles in the back
of that pickup truck
what they were saying about the person
they were going to serve the warrant
to serve them a death sentence we can
only imagine what the [ __ ] they were
saying
and that's why they don't release the
footage
and that's why they won't let the family
see the footage
they know the result they see what
happened
to derek shalvin they know what'll
happen to them
it just so happens that bystanders are
the ones who recorded
george floyd being murdered
and derek shova didn't have to use a gun
to kill to eliminate the threat
so this story will continue and i know i
know we're gonna see
news about this in the coming weeks
about how these [ __ ] are
covering something up
they did it with brianna taylor they
tried to do it with george floyd
and the list goes on and on and on i
mean jesus christ we can't even
keep a [ __ ] running list there's so
many goddamn names
but that body cam footage is our footage
it's ours it's the american people it's
the citizens of north carolina
and it's the family of andrew brown's
and their right to see
why their relative why their family
member
was killed and we need to pass
that george floyd police policing act
so that way it's instituted in law
so there isn't none of this nonsense of
it's not public record public record it
is
they're police officers they're paid
with tax dollars
that footage is ours is the is the
property of people north carolina
the citizens of that municipality who
wherever that [ __ ] body cam
footage is placed on a vest and the
family members are the people who are
killed by those officers
so we will know more about this case and
we will hear about it and i'm sure
i'm sure we'll find the [ __ ] that's
in it as well
it ain't the last time we've heard the
name andrew brown
now rather justice is served that's the
next question
can there be justice will there be
justice
i don't give a [ __ ] if they were serving
a warrant for whatever the [ __ ]
they were serving there's human there's
a thing called humanity
and the death sentence isn't always the
right thing in this culture of kill
something that's a threat
kill anything that moves [ __ ] it kill
anything that moves
needs to stop we need to stop giving
weapons
to these dumb [ __ ] that think that [ __ ]
i don't care if you're an ordinary
citizen or a goddamn officer of the law
that's your mentality you shouldn't have
a semi-automatic weapon in your hand
for sure death and destruction is the
only thing it causes
so let's move on to the next subject
that we want to talk about today because
i know everyone's dying dying to hear
what's going to happen with the attorney
general of the state of new york
and the trump organization how is this
all going to play out
and how does it all pin itself together
because there's a lot of criminal
activity
around certain people in this country
and most the time
it all the dots lead back to one
[ __ ]
and that's the the orange deity
the cheeto mussolini as it were
donald j trump
it's not only do we have the criminal
investigation where the tax returns were
presented to a
grand jury in the manhattan district
attorney's office
that the supreme court ruled on and i'm
going to show you a video about that
here in a minute that i did back in
february
and i called this folks i called it
but you have the civil investigation
into the trump organization by the
attorney general the
the state of new york and they
apparently the the reports are that they
have joined the criminal investigation
with the manhattan d.a
we also could see a lot of federal cases
come out here
about the insurrection and the and the
kangaroo coup that took place on january
6th
[Music]
maybe maybe mr trump and his allies have
some
some criminal liabilities there
not to mention not to mention the
possibility of
election felonies that happened in
georgia
with a phone call we all remember that
three days before january 6th
he made phone calls oh we gotta overturn
this thing i'm gonna lose
then we have ties to the the joel
greenberg and the matt gatz case
where roger stone was apparently paid
250 000
to lobby donald trump it always comes
back to this [ __ ]
to lobby donald trump when he was the
president united states
to give joel greenberg a goddamn pardon
for the 38 crimes that he committed
apparently how the hell they were gonna
sort that out with pardons i don't know
but the word on the street and the
reports is is that roger stone
text and was petitioning jared kushner
and rudy giuliani
for those pardons and if you don't think
that that is
that that can't be the way that it was
you just go back and you look at the
january 17th
when ivanka trump jared kushner rudy
giuliani went to the white house
and they were all in there all in there
meeting with the president
last minute pardons
i wonder if joel greenberg's name came
up
i wonder if roger stone's name came up
because he pardoned roger stone he
pardoned steve bannon he
he pardoned a bunch of seditionist
treasonous [ __ ]
so i would imagine that joel greenberg
and max
gatt's name came up why do you think all
these people were so [ __ ] desperate
for him to win
donald trump jr rudy giuliani
matt gatz
why do you think they were so desperate
for him to win
it's because the clock was ticking the
pardoned coaster was
closing and the line was [ __ ] long
for the pardon coaster
so let me play a video now again this
video is from
february
this video is from february
and it's when the supreme court decided
that yes
the manhattan d.a can have the tax
returns
to present to a grand jury this was back
in february
when that news was announced so let me
play that and i'll talk about it on the
other side desperate donny's day in
court
let's talk so our ex-cry baby in chief
finds out that his supreme court justice
nominees
didn't do him that much [ __ ] good
they allow the manhattan d.a
to present this douchebags tax returns
to a grand jury we get to find out what
this fat slob was hiding this whole time
you dumb [ __ ] what are we gonna find out
there you cheeto dust mobster is it all
the
porn star and abortion hush payment or
give me the [ __ ] laundering of
russian's money my bet is that it's a
dick contest to this [ __ ] fool and
we're gonna find out he's
[ __ ] flat broke whatever the reason
is you fascist sack of [ __ ]
you better start learning how to keister
big macs and diet coke
you dumb [ __ ] in the end i guess this
[ __ ] wasn't that good at
climbing and stuff [ __ ] them
so i surmised that he would that donald
trump
uh in jail or prison wherever wherever
he ends up
would need to keister big macs and diet
coke you know those are his two favorite
little
things is uh his big macs and diet cokes
now
i i i would imagine that the q anon
manga trump bumpers
uh wouldn't appreciate that much because
i think mcdonald's
and coca-cola is on the boycott you know
cancer culture list or whatever the [ __ ]
it is
now because you know uh for some reason
they don't bow at the altar of trump or
whatever the hell the reason uh but
they're on those lists so
i'm sure they would be very upset that
that would be the case
but i also surmise what's in this tax
returns
and what what it shows and uh what it'll
uncover
rather there's uh you know abortion uh
cover-up payments porn start cover-up
payments which we know there's
porn star cover-up payments we know that
shit's true
uh we seen the check with the signature
on it when he's the president united
states
right now to check the stormy daniels so
of course that shit's true
we know this motherfucker's been
laundering russian money through his
properties his hotels his
[ __ ] empty buildings is what they are
we know he's been doing that for years
but the thing the thing that i think
he's been trying to hide the most with
these tax returns because he don't care
about committing crime he thinks he can
get away with whatever the [ __ ] he wants
he thinks he can get ever get away with
whatever the [ __ ] he wants he thinks
he's untouchable here
the thing that he does not want people
to know is how [ __ ] broke he actually
is
that's what he's [ __ ] concerned about
that's what he that's what he
is trying to do is trying to cover up
that he's [ __ ] broke
as a joke that it's all a [ __ ] scheme
you know this money pays for this thing
it's all a scheme to make him look like
a billionaire
that's all it is that's what he's that's
what he doesn't want them to uncover
you know the crimes is one thing god get
away without
get get get out of the crime but but boy
it would be hard to piece together a
reputation again
when you were known as the guy who was
actually broke it was all it was all
[ __ ]
now speaking of crime and civil cases
the significant part about the
i think about the new york case where
the attorney general is joining the
manhattan d.a
and announcing that this civil case has
turned into a criminal case
is this is one of the very first times
in trump's long history of being in
court
and tied up in court and having charges
against him
where uh criminal charges look
inevitable
he was always his work his way and
wiggle his way into civil court
i mean him and his father did it uh back
way back when when they
when they were uh receiving government
money for housing
and they were discriminating against
people
and they tied that up in civil court
there's been all kinds kinds of times
where this guy's
is avoided criminal court well it
doesn't look like he's going to avoid a
criminal court this time
now rather it's the state of new york or
the federal government
he's i don't do not think he's going to
evade a criminal
charges or criminal indictment here
and i mean maybe maybe just maybe if you
look at
if you look at all these cases together
that surround trump and the trump
universe
that are going on right now uh you have
the the joel greenberg case in florida
where matt gatz it seems inevitable that
this guy is going to be charged with
some sort of tr sex trafficking or
possession of drugs or distribution of
drugs there could be a number of things
that this guy
has liability matt gets and i do call
him matt
getz it's not gates he wants he wants
you to call him gates but that's not how
it's [ __ ] spelled
so i ain't gonna say it that way [ __ ]
him [ __ ] him
it's gets matt gets him and his [ __ ]
forehead too
now that case there it ties to trump
with this with this [ __ ] pardon
payment
that was made to roger stone to pardon
him from the crimes that
now he's pleading guilty to in federal
court
well his plea deal comes
very soon after mr rudy giuliani's
electronic devices were seized by the
fbi did you notice that
did you notice that
and the word was that possibly
roger stone was petitioning rudy
giuliani and jared kushner
to help lobby for joel greenberg's
pardons to donald trump
when he was still president and we had
rudy giuliani being raided and his
electronics being seized by the fbi
the federal government right before joel
greenberg
took his plea deal now i i believe joel
greenberg's plea deal was inevitable
uh they had the goods on that
[ __ ] and they were gonna squeeze
him until he
till he popped and he popped
now the question is what did he pop for
what did he give him what is he getting
in return
that's going to be the question here
that's what time is going to tell here
and that's what these the superseding
indictments will tell as well
because there's going to be many
superseding indictments
and you're going to hear the words
conspiracy conspiracy conspiracy
just like just like you're going to see
uh with the
the insurrection on january 6 which
we're going to get to
because i believe that there's a
shitload of federal cases
that are already tied to the january 6th
event
i mean jesus christ marjorie taylor
green was out crying her eyes out on the
on the house floor yesterday about how
the treasonous insurrectionist
who created who committed the slews of
federal crimes treason basically
sedition trespassing
and they're abused oh they're they're so
abused
siding siding with the insurrectionist
because you know it was just a normal
tour of the capital
but here we go again we have federal
cases
federal criminal cases all the dots lead
back to one [ __ ]
and a handful of [ __ ]
hmm
the other thing that you have to
consider is rudy giuliani
his his devices this warrant was served
and all of a sudden all of a sudden the
new york attorney general decides
civil to criminal on the trump
organization
now i don't believe that the rudy
giuliani raid has much to do with that
if anything at all
i think the main key point of the new
york attorney general's
case turning from from civil
to criminal is weisselberg and the
squeeze on weisselberg weisselberg is
the cfo of the trump organization
him and his family there was a feud uh
his daughter-in-law's pissed off she's
yelling and screaming
probably uh burying every
every conversation that they had with
receipts
uh you had michael cohen who was
federally charged was pled guilty was
sentenced
uh he seemed to be cooperating not just
with the feds but also with the
manhattan d.a and possibly the attorney
general
of new york michael michael cohen may
know a few things about the trump
organization
he may be able to tie some knots that
weisselberg will
will finish up
it's all coming together and it takes
time it takes time
now in the meantime in the meantime not
only
not only do we have donald trump start a
blog
he's a [ __ ] blogger now what the
actual
[ __ ] is going on he's a blogger and he
does open mics at weddings at mar-a-lago
this is where his career has gone holy
[ __ ]
he was he was a real a famous real
estate mogul
uh known as what i mean he was in rap
songs movies
he was in pop culture as if he was the
richest man on earth
he had his own reality tv show where he
got to pretend to be a rich biz
a rich successful businessman
and then he ran for president
accidentally won and here he is he's a
blogger who
lives in a hotel in florida who lost his
job
oh that is that that you just you can't
make this [ __ ]
up you can't make this [ __ ] up
but not only is donald trump spreading
the big lie and continue to spreading
the big lie
and i'm not talking about just the
election i'm talking about anything
absolutely anything donald trump is the
big lie the big lie isn't that that the
election was stolen from him of course
everyone knows that's a [ __ ] lie
i mean jesus christ there was 60 some
cases the supreme court told them to go
[ __ ] themselves several times
even mike pence [ __ ] said no you got
to certify the results and they wanted
to hang his ass for doing it
literally wanted to hang him hang mike
pence that's what they were cheering
outside the capitol on january 6th
they not only were they ready to commit
sedition but they wanted to
overturn the the the government of the
united states
i don't think those boneheads understood
what they were talking about because
they were deluded
and and and we had news on that we see
that the the q
shaman the buffalo guy you know the guy
with the [ __ ] horns
the the q anon the q anon buffalo
and whatever the [ __ ] he is his lawyer
says
uh something about the short bus he he's
not all there and neither are these
did the the cue and honors which i i
mean you can you can
throw the short bus phrase however you
want to look at it you know you can be
offended or not be offended
but he's not that far off these people
these people are
education has been lost to these people
lost to these people they're so far away
from
from being able to critically think it's
not even funny
now rather that has anything to do with
a short bus or their mental capacity
just [ __ ] who knows
i mean i i know some really smart people
that believe some really deluded things
and it's only because they want to
believe them because it supports their
narrative and what they want to believe
which is lies
but we have the the the q anon shamans
lawyer
uh mounting a defense for these people
because that's their only defenses were
yeah we didn't know what we were doing
we had no clue what we were doing
i mean they're on [ __ ] camera they
were live streaming themselves their
[ __ ] cell phones that they were live
streaming with the evidence is in the
metadata
they were there they were there
you're not gonna get around that it was
it wasn't antipa
it was them and they're [ __ ] and that
whole antifa it was black lives matter
antifa boy that's died
that's died of death in a hurry hasn't
it now it's all they were great patriots
taking a tour of the capitol
yeah [ __ ] break
and we need we need a january 6
commission or a special counsel either
way
now the republicans better get on board
with this [ __ ] commission because
i would rather see a special counsel
myself i'd rather see the department of
justice come in
and take all these cases that they
already have in federal court
and really do a special counsel and and
and
sniff out every [ __ ] seditious
[ __ ]
underneath every goddamn rock i don't
care if they're
if they're joe blow from wherever
wearing a maga hat
or if it's a goddamn member of congress
a senator
a cabinet member a personal attorney of
a president united states
or the president united the former
president united states himself
that's what i prefer but i mean the
republicans can can have it the way that
they want
because this this idea that somehow they
could just rewrite history these [ __ ]
boneheads
haven't we had about enough of this
america them trying to rewrite and
whitewash history jesus christ
i mean they these people do it all the
time with the confederate flag and the
civil war
it wasn't about slavery that was about
states rights
they continued with the confederate
statues oh that's our heritage
forget about when they were put up or
why they were put up or the context
in which they were put up they continue
on and on and on
that flag represents my heritage and
southern pride
on and on and on they go whitewashing
and re trying to rewrite what
what the [ __ ] reality is and they'll
continue to do it and they're doing it
with january 6.
i mean last week in a goddamn committee
hearing they were talking about how
it was just a regular every everyday
average tour of the capital
there was no violence everyone's seen
the tapes
give me a [ __ ] break yeah everyone's
seen the tapes everyone knows
it's not a [ __ ] secret
and the only people who are gonna go
along with this are the people who
want to believe it and the reason why
they want to believe this because they
know it'll save their ass
and it saves their narrative that's it
that's it because a nine nine eleven
style commission
that would investigate the january 6th
insurrection
the way that they have it written now
would be able to subpoena members of
congress
and that is not what the republicans
want they do not
want that [ __ ] that [ __ ] they do not
want to be subpoenaed
why do you think josh hawley months ago
was asking about metadata
and if the fbi received metadata
metadata
and recorded metadata i wonder why
huh could it be that that metadata will
show evidence
that not not only were they complicit
but they were they were
they were actively planning with these
people
i mean we heard about tours and we know
there were tours of the capital
we know they were showing them where to
go and what to do come on
that's what they're scared of the truth
why do you think they cast lose cheney
aside
because they're scared of the truth and
don't get me wrong liz cheney is no
[ __ ] hero of the truth here
it just so happens when you're on the
opposite side of trump you look like a
truth hero
you look like you're pro-democracy all
of a sudden when you're on the opposite
side of trump that's real [ __ ] easy
to do in this day and age when the big
lies being spread around and by the big
lie
i mean trump trump is the big lie
he is it's him it's trumpism
it's that entire mechanism that they're
using to spread their hate and fascism
that's the big lie it ain't got nothing
to do with this election
jesus christ we watch the maricopa
county down in arizona the audit
that they have it's getting just
obliterated
they'll be lucky if there's not federal
criminal charges with that [ __ ] case
with these morons thinking that they're
going to do an audit and bungling audit
breaking laws based on the information
that they were holding and how they were
using it
big trouble but this january 6
commission
to investigate the insurrection on
january 6
this is republicans best bet as far as
i'm concerned
this is their best bet because if they
really don't
make sure that they get some kind of uh
commission that they have control of
that they have some control of of what
the outcome
or what the facts may bear and how many
facts the public actually get to see
there may be a special counsel and for
the next
for the next two at three and a half
years
the bite administration is gonna have
the reins on the department of justice
it's not gonna be bill barr trying to
squash a mueller investigation
four words merrick [ __ ] garland
[ __ ]
that's what stands in the way so i mean
they can have it however they [ __ ]
want it
they can have it as a 911 style
commission
which is crazy that they would talk into
a microphone and say we don't want a 911
style commission because
we're the terrorists
holy [ __ ] that's where we've come in 20
years in this country
that's where we come as george bush
standing on a pile of rubble
with a bullhorn saying we will smoke you
out we will come get you
whatever we have to do wherever we have
to go we will find you
to know we don't want a 911 style
commission jesus christ can you imagine
can you imagine if we have a 911 style
commission for january 6 good god we'll
all go to prison
we'll all be charged with federal crimes
good lord can you imagine
yeah i can't imagine i can't imagine
what you [ __ ] did that day
so i did a tick tock of course on this
today this is
this for a long time this has been one
of my favorite
favorite tick tocks because my target is
actually mitch mcconnell
and kevin mccarthy the mick traders
themselves
because they are the ones who are saying
nope we're not going to do this
commission and they're whipping votes
and and and uh to to to
look even more desperate whipping votes
to be against this is not
it it's not even gonna uh help
and the reason why it's not gonna help
is because you don't have majorities and
the reason why you don't have majorities
is because of trumpism is because of
trump because you people perpetuated
this nonsense
the big lie trump you perpetuated him
for four [ __ ] years
and that's why you lost the president
the presidential race
you lost the house and the senate and
now you don't have the majorities
so you can whip all the [ __ ] votes
you want all it'll do is prove to us
that you're voting against something
that makes sense to do
just like anything else you're gonna
[ __ ] vote against
i mean jesus christ josh hawley voted
against the stop asian hate act
and 62 members of the house republicans
said nope not we really we really should
let people
you know hate on asians because of the
coronavirus that's what we should do
that's a good idea [ __ ] that
we don't need to protect people from
discrimination
this is where we're at this is where
we're at
and it's a good goddamn thing that we're
here because the daylight is being the
best disinfectant here
daylight is the best disinfectant
they're
wide out in the open with their fascism
white out in the open so let's watch my
little tick tock that i did today
and then we'll do the thing that we
always do and talk about that
[ __ ] on
tourism terrorism potato tomato
let's talk big traders kevin mccarthy
and moscow mitch mcconnell
do not want a commission looking into
the january 6th treasonous insurrection
i wonder why it be that them and some of
their members were trying to overthrow
the government of the united states
yeah no [ __ ] sherlock they're gonna let
the seditious traders vote on whether
we should investigate them or not jesus
[ __ ] christ don't like this 911 style
commission [ __ ]
that's because they're the [ __ ]
terrorists just think about it wouldn't
it been [ __ ] swell if the 911
terrorists got to vote not to be
investigated
jesus would have been even better if
they would have had a propaganda cable
news show
called schmucker carlson or some [ __ ]
like that
how to spread the fear and their
terrorist lies around
leave your eyes it was just a regular
plane ride on a tour of the world trade
centers
connor mccarthy and all you treason is
manga trump bumpers in congress
go munch on a big bag of horse dicks
[ __ ] em
you know had to throw a big bag of horse
dicks in there why not
when it's mcconnell and mccarthy uh
a big bag of horse accents sounds about
right
it's hard to even move on from from the
big bag of horse ticks
so oh the image
the image of mccarthy and mcconnell
sharing a big buffet of of horse dicks
for breakfast is fantastic isn't it
someone
someone out there whoever's out there
listening who draws political cartoons
get your ass to work i don't draw them
but
i know there's someone who will i know
there is someone who will
so get to drawing
but really if you think about it this is
about appropriate
they really want us to believe
if we if we put the 911 style commission
in context of the january 6 commission
they really want us to believe that the
planes
that flew into the twin towers
was somehow just a regular plane ride
they were just going to take a tour of
the twin towers
and it just so happens that they crashed
into the building
that that's all it was it was just an
accident
and we shouldn't we shouldn't
investigate bin laden we should
investigate jihadist around the world we
definitely shouldn't start a 20-year war
over it we definitely shouldn't hold
terrorists at guantanamo uh so that way
we can evade
all laws and all due process for those
people and lock them up for
however [ __ ] long we want to and
torture them as much as we want
to we definitely definitely definitely
should not do that
that's the context these are the same
republicans
and the reason why is because now
they're the terrorists they're the
domestic terrorists
they do not want themselves to be
investigated
and in this commission in this bill
it gives the commission the power to
subpoena the members
that's what they're against it divides
up the power almost equally i mean yeah
the majority leader chuck schumer and
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi
get the p
get the pick the chairman but mitch
mcconnell and
and and kevin mccarthy get to pick the
vice chairman and it's evenly divided
and the other thing too is these people
have to have a certain amount of time
out of politics they can't be
hold current office and then they get to
choose these people
it's not like we're drawing these people
out of a out of a damn
hat gonna do
a commission style bingo no
they get control of it the thing that
they're terrified of
is the subpoena power that this
commission would have
they don't want the public to know
what their involvement was in january 6
they do not want them to know that
and the reason why they don't want them
to know is because they're a narrative
of january 6 will fall the [ __ ] apart
that it was it wasn't incited
it wasn't planned it was it just it just
so happened there were a bunch of really
nice people with maga hats on
that just decided to go take a tour of
the capitol and things got out of
control a little bit
that's what they want us to believe and
it's not true
we all seen it we all know but the thing
that they really don't want us to know
other than what we've seen is what we
didn't see
what is it that we didn't see i mean
jesus christ
rudy giuliani was trying to call tommy
tuberville
that day to get them to stall as long as
they possibly could
and he accidentally was calling other
people because rudy giuliani does not
know how to operate a phone
he obviously does not know how to
operate electronic devices
and that's probably going to be more
evident when we hear about what the fbi
and the feds
what they got from his electronic
devices who knows who the [ __ ] he
butt dialed or miscalled and to commit
federal crimes but we'll find out i
guess over time
but he was he was making phone calls to
get them to try to stall
the certification of the result which
there was no stopping it folks
it didn't matter if they voted on that
or not it doesn't
that doesn't [ __ ] matter it's all
theatrics as far as the government and
institutions are concerned
the constitution didn't give a [ __ ] the
constitution would not
give a [ __ ] if if january 6th
if they wouldn't have voted on on on the
certification of the electoral college
are not
that's not in the original constitution
in the first place
and and joe biden would have been
constitutionally the president anyways
because the states already certified
their own results
the congress certifying is just
theatrics it's make them [ __ ] feel
important
and this boneheaded thing that the vice
president has the ability to crown a
king is [ __ ] dumb too
now he could have stood up there and
said it but it wouldn't have made it
true
it would have caused a constitutional
crisis for sure
but mike pence knew that that was not
the way for donald trump to become
to remain president so he could save his
ass his family's ass
and everyone else who had committed
crimes around himself because that
is apparently what is happening we can
see it now can't you see it
can't you see why they were so [ __ ]
desperate for him to be president united
states
they don't give a [ __ ] about how good or
how bad of a president he was
he would cover up their crimes that's
what they wanted
that's why they were so desperate that's
why they're continuing to be so
desperate
that's why they perpetuate believe this
nonsense and somehow
on september 89th donald trump is gonna
ascend from the heavens and
he's gonna take over from mar-a-lago and
control the military and push a button
or
i don't know some dumb [ __ ] some about
dominoes dropping with these states
and audits what the [ __ ] apparently
today wisconsin told them to go [ __ ]
themselves with their audit
michigan's tell them to go [ __ ]
themselves they probably won't get one
in pennsylvania
georgia is already investigating crimes
into
voter intimidation with these people
give me a [ __ ] break
[ __ ] boneheads so enough is enough of
this [ __ ]
so republicans as far as i'm concerned
can go kick rocks
they can either be on with this this
this january 6
9 11 style commission
and have control over it or not and
merrick garland and the department of
justice can appoint a special counsel to
investigate january 6
and they'll have more [ __ ] subpoena
power than the than the january 6
commission would ever dream of
go ahead i bet merrick garland will be
your huckleberry
this next 18 months we're all gonna have
to have
criminal justice degrees here to figure
out what the hell is going on
it's just going to be just a a big huge
massive pile
of trump horse [ __ ] trump criminal horse
[ __ ] all of it
so you might as well bone up you might
as well get your your goddamn little
wall dictionaries out
and start studying up not just on on
federal criminal law but the state of
new york
the state of florida the state of
georgia and possibly the state of
arizona
and anywhere else these manga q anon
criminals are
perpetuating their lies you're gonna
need it
you're gonna [ __ ] need it
so thanks for joining me today we're
we're at almost 48 minutes i usually
talk for about an hour
do you guys like the length of these
podcasts to talk for an hour
it's uh i mean you know i could talk for
12 hours about this stuff
but an hour seems to be right about the
right spot
and if you like the podcast i really do
appreciate you guys listening
and tuning in uh we we
we stream on youtube live and then it's
up on youtube after that we stream on
twitter live and you can always go to my
twitter feed what i try to do
is when i have the the live feed i try
to keep it in the feed at the top so you
don't have to search through
and you can listen to it on on twitter
now it's a little clunky uh because you
can't fast forward or anything like that
but you can
certainly listen to the live stream on
twitter or re-watch it on twitter
or you can go to the link on the youtube
the best part is the best part is you
don't even have to get on youtube or
twitter if you don't want to
you can you can listen to it on spotify
or apple podcast and there's a lot of
other platforms but let's face it
the the apple podcast and the spotify is
the walmart and target
of podcast so that's where you're gonna
end up the coke and pepsi as it were
so that's where you're gonna end up and
if you really enjoy the podcast
and i appreciate all you guys uh brandy
says
brandy says keep going keep going i'm
gonna keep going
i don't care if no one listens i'm gonna
keep yelling and screaming into a
microphone
but to keep going to keep going it cost
a little bit of money to publish the
podcast and use the software that i got
here with all the
well over here the all the fancy
graphics and the and the stuff down
below
and the streaming in different locations
so it takes a little bit to do that
stuff so if you
would like to support the podcast that
would be fantastic you can go to
thetonymichaels.com you go to the merch
store
you get some [ __ ] stickers everyone
likes [ __ ] them and
and also there's [ __ ] hats you can go
to the tonymichaels.com and see the hats
that i wear
so if you want one of those you can you
can pick one of those up
all that stuff if you if you purchase
any that goes to helping the podcast
stay up on spotify and apple podcast and
on youtube and
and keeping it streaming and all those
places so i'd appreciate any of the
support there
and i really appreciate you guys
listening today
follow me on twitter follow me on
tic-tac come
subscribe on youtube and until next week
at wednesday three o'clock
central four o'clock eastern
[ __ ] um you've been listening to the
tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news
no rules no boundaries i think we've
made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon
in the meantime follow tony on social
media
at the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them